hey guys i'm ryan wright there's a new
trailer out the second trailer for
teenage mutant ninja turtles i really
like the first one i am hoping i will
like the second one i am hoping we see
more of megan fox the actress that
nobody is happy is in this but she is
good eye candy for this guy who loves to
masturbate every eight hours just like a
job joke nailed anyway guys
let's watch this trailer
okay it's
green just like the ninja turtles
you know a movie's good when it says
nickelodeon violence and fear have run
rampant
our great city is being destroyed
transformers robots in disguise
transfers
people want justice restored to this
world
a white guy into asians
but heroes are not born
they're created
that's what your father and i were
trying to do i don't give a [ __ ] what
anyone says this really is gonna be
awesome
create heroes
nice
no they're back
cool
chill it's just a mask see don't freak
out
right
overall that was a lot like the first
trailer for ninja turtles movie it is
taking itself very serious which is kind
of weird to me because it's about mutant
size turtles and it's their splinter
talking rat or mout whatever i know one
of you guys are gonna get so pissed off
of me for getting it wrong so i'm not
gonna go with either yes shredder he
ain't japanese uh i kind of like what
they're doing with the story having it
be like yeah we were trying to create
heroes matthew mcconaughey i don't know
why i did that voice it looks cool to me
it just looks like a fun awesome time it
looks like yeah for a turtles movie it's
taking itself really serious but [ __ ] it
i'm sure there's gonna be some comedy
it's from legendary producer michael bay
he doesn't do anything wrong wouldn't
you guys agree it's just re-solidifying
that it's just gonna be a fun action
time i hope we get more humor though i
don't care that the turtles are ugly i
mean everyone's got pissed off the fact
that they're ugly and that they're not
like cute and adorable turtles or
whatever cool looking in that sense but
i think they look cool and it makes
sense for them to be ugly if they're
real they probably freak the [ __ ] out of
us think about it it's probably time for
me to masturbate again anyway guys if
you're new to the channel why don't you
go ahead and uh
subscribe
i haven't got anything today this is
shout out time let me get something
straight here i go in order of shout out
requests okay some of you guys are
trying to rip off my ball sack because
they're like hey you said i get a shout
out it's been two days well dude several
people have asked quite a few hundred
actually so
you wait your turn that's why you're
gonna watch a special video coming up
soon adam apocalypse acolytes you know
who you are you want one for the green
inferno haven't had a chance to check
out that trailer yet so you're next on
the list and like i said i'm just being
fair adam sorry that you didn't get it
on your green inferno video but here it
is now you can take it or leave it be
happy be satisfied go over your wife and
kids try to make love to your fat wife
tonight enjoy your life okay i'm sorry
adam you didn't deserve that i was
taking all my anger on you you're a good
guy
you're a you've always been there for me
cedric martinez this guy i can't reply
back to him for some reason it upsets me
look if i like like hit the like button
on one of your comments that means i
couldn't reply back that's not because i
was too lazy or i didn't find your
comment interesting that's just not my
style i just couldn't comment back at
the time because your account won't
allow me to so fix your [ __ ] account
cedric so i can comment back to you
[ __ ] sorry cedric
youtube first it was adam now it's you
and i'm just a really bad person chris
osterman long time subscriber comments
frequently this dude he's been with us
like since the beginning practically so
thank you chris osterman you're a cool
guy and sometimes you defend me when
other people get on my ass see chris you
understand when people like adam and
cedric are ganging up on me i'm sorry
guys i i know you guys are gonna do
anything mean to me it's just tough
giving up all these shout outs you know
reading off this list you do three shout
outs and then you're like oh here comes
another 10 to just get mad at you for
not shouting out their name sorry guys
damn you cedric and adam thanks chris
for backing me up like that man you have
my backpack there you're a good guy pull
down your pants let's do this
that's me choking on the dick i don't
think i could ever suck a guy's dick